need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation what's up believe nation
8 7 I believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
having his dreams of becoming an NFL
player being crushed by getting an
injury being left with only seven
dollars in his pocket to becoming one of
the greatest wrestlers of all time and
one of Hollywood's biggest stars he's
Dwayne the rock Johnson and here's my
take on his top ten roses success vol 3
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one remember the hard times so before a
big movie comes out before back in the
days when I was wrestling with WWE a
WrestleMania match anything big that
would happen I would always take a
moment and I just remind myself all
right I was evicted when I was 14 we
were kicked off the island we couldn't
live in Hawaii had no place to live a
lot happened then when I moved to
Nashville as arrested multiple times by
the time I was 16 years old I got
remember that if I were playing on this
team which might you know my skills are
what's that term oh the sheets so I
never play but before I lace up before I
get on the court before I playing these
big games before I go to the Staples
Center where history says those are
those are historic will Hall Sahara at
the Staples Center I would remember that
and it allows me then to be present in
the moment and understand holy SH that's
the stuff I have around me right now
this is the that I dreamed of when I was
a kid I am here what helps me is to keep
the hard times in the front of my mind
because it allows me to go into these
big moments that I've worked my ass off
and you guys have worked your ass off it
allows me to go into these big moments
with a different perspective
rule number two just be you at this
point in your career where most people
would be like hey get those cameras away
I don't talk to anybody every single day
you talking to the people why is it it's
the most important relationship I have
is with the people as I reached a point
in my career I was tired of trying to be
something I wasn't Wow
so I was told at that time listen you
can't talk about wrestling you can't go
by the rock you can't be as big again
yeah it was a lot of things like that so
finally I reached a point where I said
all right two things have to happen I'm
gonna surround myself with a different
group of people different management and
and then I'm gonna make sure that that I
just got to be me right me and if you
want to call me rocky call me rock Yeah
right I'm gonna get no cuz I was like I
should come no yes of course
no it's always Rock rule number three be
nice when it comes to kindness or being
nice it's very very easy for me I heard
something when I was fifteen years old
I'll never forget it and this was at a
time where we were struggling to pay the
rent and living paycheck to paycheck and
the quote that I heard was it's nice to
be important but it's more important to
be nice and I remember hearing that I
thought man I hope one day maybe fingers
crossed
God willing universe willing whatever
that I'm considered important that it
would matter if I'm nice to people so
yeah it's very very easy and also you
know life is much easier when you're
nice and you're not foolish really
before commit fully I wrestled John Cena
and I went in and I think it's 2013 I
went in WWE Champion and we went in
MetLife Stadium we we had a
record-breaking attendance which was
amazing that night we accomplished our
goal so I wrestle with John Cena we had
45 minutes planned for the match it's
nonstop and go right so your
conditioning is tested we get to MetLife
Stadium it's a big night this is its
game night right it's its championship
night for me
45-minute matches planned out there's no
cut
there's no all right well let's pick it
back up tomorrow you know it's go time
it's just like you guys in a game at the
15-minute mark
bang
I feel some pop on my boom laying there
and both of us are out I said off
something's going on and I stick my head
now it's 85,000 people right we're just
laid out like this I kind of roll over I
stick my hand down in my trunk just to
see I want to make sure that there was
no bone sticking out so if there's no
bone sticking out what the something
just happened referee comes over and
he's like rocky alright yeah yeah yeah I
think I'm all right I said I get up I go
to step and I can't stop I can't do this
I have to use my leg like momentum
I got do that so now in that moment and
you guys are gonna have these moments
you've probably already had them already
where you're in the game and you're in
the thick of things and you got to make
a decision where I got to do I'm gonna
stay in the game
committed to the team I committed to my
team the whole entire roster right and
in the world of wrestling when you have
a big show like this and you have a big
main event that the entire show is based
around the wrestlers will come up to the
two people in the main event
at some point all throughout the night
in the locker room and just like hey
thank you for the house I appreciate it
thank you for the house and what that
means is that's a way of saying thank
you for drawing helping draw eighty five
thousand people and putting a lot of
money in my paycheck in my bank account
thank you for the house we got a lot of
thank you for the houses that night Oh
bang this happens and now I realize I
can't move my leg I got 30 minutes left
of this match and it's not just like
around I mean these are like we got to
put on a show there's a lot of big
flying and suplexes all that so I could
tell the wrestlers are you okay and I
have one moment in this moment it was a
defining moment I could either tell him
no I'm done he gives the signal matches
over or let's keep going
and again this is a little takeaway for
you guys if you ever have this moment
I'm sure you have if you haven't it's
coming we have this decision
I said no let's keep going I said how
much time is up he's like thirty two
minutes okay rest of the whole match
couldn't move doing everything like this
I'm getting scared because I'm thinking
man well what happens if I if I if I
pinch something or something like you
know I don't know your mind starts with
you in the moment there's 85,000 people
your Adrenaline's rushing like a man
what happens we're going to lose my leg
or something like this if I've just done
something to my artery final move of the
match is his big finishing move and I
remember I'm getting up and I'm turning
like this because I have to fall into
him he's gonna hit me with his big
finisher it's like a massive suplex when
I go over his head and slams me down and
I remember turning I remember turning
into John and he says and I remember
thinking myself god please don't let
this be too bad just take care of me
take care of me bang I feel boom this
happened now lucky leave matches over he
pins me when she comes in the back get
to the back I can't move now getting a
little nervous
and doctors come in John comes in you
okay he comes in it was like to
celebrate with booze he brings like
moonshine like legit moonshine that's
like crazy white boys that they bring
like in a jar his moonshine hey let's
have some more chances okay don't know
what's happening rush get on a jet
rushed home to my doctors down in
Florida and get an MRI find out that I
have completely torn my adductor the top
of my my a doctor and my top of my quad
off my pelvis yes
really really so it's a very long story
to tell you what I was proud of was to
walk out on my own but not only that but
in this moment where the odds are
against you people are watching you
teams depending on you you either say
I'm done
or this whatever the [ __ ] is going on
it's temporary and it made me up at some
point down the road but I'm not gonna
let this opportunity go by without
giving it my all rule number five
overcome adversity I was evicted when I
was 14 years old and then we were forced
off the Island of Hawaii to move of all
places we had to moved to Nashville and
we lived in a little motel and I was
trying to remain as positive as I could
and now your company is called seven
butts why is that seven bucks so my goal
was a plane an FL and that didn't happen
for me I went up to the Canadian
Football League I played up there I got
cut from there flew back down to Miami
my old man was living in Tampa mm-hmm I
said I called him at midnight when I
land I said you got to come get me on
the way back up to Tampa I said God you
know let me see how much money I got I
pulled out my wallet opened it up I took
out a 5 a 1 and change and that's why we
have 7 bucks
7 bucks for that rule number 6 take risk
I'm making the transition in Hollywood
there was no blueprint before me so it
wasn't like I I can say oh there's that
other black Samoan wrestler who was like
over sixth floor and Wayde whatever
pounds it was a time where I just I was
still trying to find my footing in
Hollywood and still trying to understand
how I fit into this machine and I was
enamored and motivated by the
opportunity to play on a platform that I
hadn't before and coming from the world
of wrestling which was very crazy wild
world of wrestling so there was a time
where I was little concerned with how I
fit in and also if I was even going to
fit in but yeah years later I'm very
fortunate to be sitting here now rule
number seven make an impact film has the
gives me the biggest opportunity to make
the biggest impact global impact I don't
want to make small movies I love and
respect our movie business but I want to
make big movies that do well and when
they do well it's not the money thing
because we have money right money's good
money's good
it ebbs and flows it's the idea
I can impact as many people as possible
with a big global movie and when the
global movie is touching a billion
dollars that sounds good right it's good
for the bank account's good for
everybody involved everybody's getting
their piece of cake it's great but what
that does do it I know I'm impacting
people around the world by giving them
some good entertainment making them feel
good rule number eight don't give up
when I was 15 or 16 years old I went on
an addition for for a soap opera and I
forgot which one it was I drove to New
York we're downtown and I read for it
and I had no acting experience at all I
probably got through four lines before
they had said that's fantastic but you
know why I think we're gonna go into a
different direction thank you very much
and I was like oh okay great but I did
great he knows it's very genuine I'd do
good I wanted feedback and they were
like yeah sure no you did you did great
absolutely somebody get that cardboard
box and just said of here because it
probably just the same and then I had
another audition with Stephen Sommers
that was my big audition for The Mummy
Returns I had one line in the movie and
that wasn't even English it was Egyptian
dialogue it was a kuma shantae and I'll
never forget it it probably means are
you silly enough to actually say these
lines and I was at that time
rule number nine do not be outworked I
[Music]
feel like for me it feels seamless
because you're prepared for so long but
it's just like you guys prepping for a
game that's the fun part
that's where sigh it's fun and people
are paying their hard-earned dollars to
come see you they're cheering they're
going bananas they're booing it out of
you are on the road it's that's fun
that's what you live for I mean that's
the juice right there the prep is where
the character is made and I just don't
mean the character I play I mean the
character in here so for me the prep is
getting with the director getting with
the producers getting with the writers
getting with the getting with the so in
essence it's like getting with all your
coaches and your different position
coaches and and all the meetings that
you have to have right so that's the
work you put in the key for me was where
does it start
what's the anchor what's the anchor so I
could have all these ambitions and you
guys have all these ambitions which is
great it's important I'll play this role
you'll play that role I'll execute this
thing and it'll come out this summer
you guys will execute this thing during
the summer right what it's time to
really put in a lot more work but the
key with me is just always finding what
the anchor is and the anchor is getting
up at 4 o'clock in the morning every day
before anybody else and grounding my
thought process is in the no one will
outwork me no one I love and I respect
you guys will that work me
I'll start with this two hands and rule
number ten the last told me for a very
special bonus clip is have fun what if
your oldest daughter told you she was
dating someone at this very moment okay
if she came to me if Simone came to me
as I listen dad I'm dating someone I was
like oh cool we'll bring him in and then
he comes in hello what's your name and
he's hey my name
right there what that is that's the
throat that I'm grabbing that means I'm
choking the life out of this boy that it
just goes down
Simone's not in the room right now
because she was escorted out yeah
and just stops down there guys what's
that thing when Oh gurgling because
you're fighting for your life
oh no we just stay down there and that's
how it rekt great
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from the rock on his advice to his
younger self on how to relax it's gonna
be okay that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing question time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one
what adversity is in front of you that
you need to overcome number two how will
you make an impact today and number
three what will you do the next time
that you want to give up
can tell my high school self something
what would it be it would be
it would be even at your lowest point
things are gonna be okay huh yeah things
are gonna be okay because there was
times like look in high school when I
was when I was like 15 men like things
were tough for us back then when I was
15 I was getting arrested still things
like that and I had thought like and
this sucks my life sucks but things got
better so I would tell myself that yeah
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more The Rock we mean a
motivational video on him that I think
you're gonna enjoy the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there it's 4:45 a.m. it's
still dark outside look at that the
lights just went out and I'm getting
ready to kill this a.m. cardio you can't
even see me but it's gonna be so good
it's bad